le crapaau quand il voit une voiture sur
la route traversée plutôt que de se
carapater au contraire il va
s'immobiliser se gonfler devant la
voiture en lui disant tu passeras pas
effectivement il y a un rapport de force
qui est un petit peu particulier voici
le crapodrome on a un filet qui fait 550
m de long donc il est enterré à 10 cm
dans le sol pour éviter que les crapeau
puissent passer par en dessous et il est
disposé tout le long de la forêt de
façon à couvrir complètement toute la
lagune c'est-à-dire l'ÉTS où les
crapeaux viennent se reproduire on a
installé tous les 15 m un saut et en
cherchant la sortie les bêtes tombent
dans le saut l'idée c'est de les
ramasser tous les matins et de les faire
traverser afin qu'il se fassent pas
écraser